et pour en parler nous sommes avec les
briques montville éditeurs auteurs du
livre julian assange en danger de mort
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous faites partie du comité wiki
justice cette organisation de défense de
julian assange
comment se porte-t-il aujourd'hui mais
ça qu'on a déposé plusieurs rapports
médicaux d un certain nombre de médecins
ont pu l'observer mais simplement pas le
haut sculptées évidemment tout ce que je
sais c'est un peu ce que disait son son
père il ne se souvient on arrive
quasiment pas articuler son propre nom
donc il est très très affaiblie
je rappelle quand même que neil smith
est rapporteur de l'onu qui avait pu le
lui rendre visite mais encore
faudrait-il qu'il y retourne me
semble-t-il qu'on voit pas pourquoi il
n'y retourne pas personnellement mais
avait dit qu'il était en et les
conditions déplorables qui sont des
conditions de torture des plaques
règlerait vais dire la malade
spécialiste aussi de ces questions
avaient avaient déjà dédié la même chose
donc mais il ya une pression qui est
suffisant il ya énormément de l'a22
médecin 60 médecins en ont fait un
rapport 177 autres ont écrit dans la
revue the lancet tu qu'il a la revue de
référence je veux dire du monde médical
dans le domaine aux gosses action sur
ces conditions médicales
c'est à dire que tout le monde est
préoccupé si vraiment ils meurent en
prison ce qui est pas à ce qui est pas
exclue vraiment le royaume uni veut
faire piètre figure je pense qu'ils
commencent à s'en rendre compte
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a un des leurs
en octobre nous annoncer une extradition
pour fin février l'a donc là comme ça
commence en fait passer leur impression
que la pression ait compris justement du
collectif ou que justice le collectif
militant à en dépensant tellement de
leur apport de sueur sur ces deux
conditions de détention sur tellement
mauvaise que j'ai l'impression qu'on est
en train de gagner du temps c'est une
très bonne chose
je viens à 100 je me rappelle est
accusée d'espionnage il risque donc 175
ans de prison aux états unis pour avoir
publié sur son site wikileaks des
documents secrets des documents qui ont
qui mettait notamment en cause l'action
de l'armée américaine en irak et en
afghanistan est ce que vous savez
comment il prépare cette journée de
non en fait non il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'informations pour
repenser pour savoir ça et puis je sais
pas si surprenante à plat préparé lui
même ce que ce conseil de l'avocat
fitzgerald c'est qui va sans
certainement assister sur les vices de
procédures et aux lieux et dieu sait
qu'on en a énormément ce qui va se
passer à partir de demain c'est qu'on
sera au moins que les chefs d'accusation
parce que quand vous parlez des 175 ans
en fait c'est une fuite qui a eu sur un
grand jury en virginie c'est à dire une
sorte d' enquête parlementaire qui donc
en fait concrètement on ne sait pas
exactement de quoi on lui reproche une
version faudrait traduire le droit
états-unien dans le droit britannique se
sont ils vous ne riez pas ce type de de
peine donc des gens savent à quel est le
chiffre de chefs d'accusation après il
ya une autre problème c'est qu'ils
responsable juridiquement de wikileaks
le seul qui possède le nom de domaine
c'est john shipton j'allais dire tant
mieux puisqu'elle a été blanchi dans une
affaire aux etats-unis contre la banque
suisse julius baer où ils avaient été
prouvés qu'ils avaient utilisé
simplement le l'amendement le premier
amendement de la constitution des états
unis qui l'autorisent active
l'amendement sur la liberté d'expression
et donc ils avaient été complètement
blanchi de cette affaire en tant que
possesseur du nom de domaine wikileaks
notre problème c'est que julian assange
si on regarde son statut était un
employé de la fondation wau holland viva
rouge la presse allemande c'est comme ça
qu'il faut penser w a eu
hollande c'est comme la région de les
pays bas avaient mords moi le set cette
fondation pour pour l wikileaks était le
projet numéro 4 s'est marqué sur le
retour sur tous leurs documents et donc
se dire c'est que voilà j'aimerais bien
que poussé tous ces gens là soient
évidemment blanchi mais j'arrive avec
une défense un peu plus collectif
pourquoi est-ce que lui tu es en train
de est sur le banc des accusés tout seul
parmi la défense française de gêne
assange il ya des personnalités du bar
paris notamment
cet avocat dupond moretti
quel va être son rôle demain ben écoute
chose que du premier rôle qui est en
train de découvrir le dossier je trouve
pas forcément mosquées les choses y
compris selon lui avait posé la question
de savoir qui étaient quittés
responsable juridiquement wikileaks est
simplement je pense qu'il est s'il
répondait pas c'est que simplement il va
découvrir un peu le la chose ce qui m'a
étonné bon c'est la mise un peu à
l'écart visiblement de juan branco parce
qu'ils étaient proche très proche des
juges garçonne et il se semble s'être
passionné pour des causes qui à mon avis
sont un peu plus ressemble à un combat
douteux comme dirait stenbeck parce que
c'est quand même pas le même niveau
c'est pas le même enjeu donc on va voir
à peu près ce qu'on veut c'est vrai que
il y aurait une filière française aura
une filière je veux dire une solution
française de d'asile politique
il ya aussi là la solution suisse qui
bien avant c'est surtout qu'elle est
elle et elle est soutenue aussi par le
soir du mouvement social notamment la
dhr et a donc vous avez une sorte de
consensus politique en suisse c'est très
suisse d'ailleurs dans cette manière de
faire donc le et en moto vous n'avez pas
de bases américaines parce que donc les
amis de julian assange qui voudraient le
disons le le ramener
chez lui c'est à dire en australie c'est
quand même le bras droit des états-unis
l'australie dans cette affaire ça me
semble ça ne sommes pas une très bonne
idée mais une solution suisses ont une
solution la française d'autant plus
qu'il a une partie de sa famille en
france me semble effectivement
envisageable selon la défense de germain
saint donald trump
or est offert au fondateur de wikileaks
de le gracier s'il admettait l'absence
d'implication russe dans la fuite
d'e-mails ses e-mails internes au parti
démocrate américain oui alors écouter
les gens qui étaient là je dis non
entièrement pas entendu ça ça semble a
fait était une interprétation d'un
certain nombre de journalistes qui
étaient là c'est pas clair du tout cette
histoire je trouve ça tout à fait
bizarre ça pas du tout été confirmée
donc là un mot peut-être cette
accusation d'espionnage selon vous en
quoi est-ce qu'elles pèsent sur la
liberté d'expression
bah écoutez les socialo le cas ferait
absolument jurisprudence pour tout le
monde et je crois que si vous voulez à
cause de cette espèce dessous du minable
affaires pawlinski on fait croire qu'en
fait il ya un problème sur la
transparence le besoin de transparence
cette idéologie de la transparence s'est
passé le cas assange s'est pas
simplement lui peut avoir une sorte
d'idéologie utopique delà de la
transparence en politique mais c'est
évidemment pas pour révéler des vies
privées c'est c'était parce qu'il était
témoin de crime
et ça c'est du droit pur que vous êtes
témoin d'un crime vous êtes tellement de
torture vous devez 7 à devoir de le
dénoncer ça n'a rien à voir avec exigé
de transparence pour jusqu'à la vie
privée ou quoi que ce soit c'est ça
quand même l'enjeu le joueur majeur
essentiel dans cette affaire merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation et
bricmont ville éditeurs auteurs de ce
livre et julian assange en danger de
mort